ويبدو لي أن ممارسة النفاق
ما تقوم به اللجنة
الأوروبي في هذه الحالة غير مقبول.
ويبدو أن المقارنة أيضا مع
حرب
أوكرانيا لأن هذا هو ما نحن عليه
رؤية الإبادة الجماعية المخطط لها ضد
بلدة
فلسطين
دعونا نأخذ netu أمام المحكمة الجنائية
الدولية بحيث يتم قراءتها على أنها
من هو مجرم
حرب
ديفوناتنا تطالب بمستوى أوروبي
العقوبات ضد الحكومة
وتدوين العقوبات المالية
يبدو أن هناك سببًا لذلك
مواصلة المساعدات بتمويل بلد ذلك
يرفض فهم السبب ويرفض ذلك
أوقفوا المذبحة
[موسيقى]
حلقة
هناك هذه الإبادة الجماعية المخطط لها
يحدث ضد شعب
فلسطين أعتقد أن كل هذا يحدث في
السياق الذي كانت فيه إسرائيل
عقود من صنع سياسة
الاحتلال غير القانوني للأراضي
الشعب الفلسطيني ايه بيسرق بيوته
قتل الناس أيضا وأيضا إيه
حسنا، سوء المعاملة والتعذيب
جانب من السجناء الموجودين
السجون الإسرائيلية نحتاج إليها
المجتمع الدولي ايه يتفاعل و
الإجابة على ما هو دون أدنى شك و
من وجهة نظري تهديد
عالمية للديمقراطية لأنه إذا كنت
إنهم يجعلون شعب فلسطين
غدا، وهو ما أصر عليه
يمكنهم فعل ذلك لأي شخص
ويبدو أن ممارسة النفاق
ما تقوم به اللجنة
الأوروبي في هذه الحالة غير مقبول.
ويبدو أن المقارنة أيضا مع
الحرب الأوكرانية التي حدثت للتو
الذي يستمر في الحدوث ويتصرف هكذا
السريع الذي كان للاتحاد الأوروبي في ذلك
العقوبات الاقتصادية على بوتين
قيادة بوتين في نفس الوقت
لقد كان رد فعله وأعتقد أن هذا هو ما
نحن نضيع الفرصة I
أنا أيضا أطالب ببلدي و
إلى بلدان أخرى أننا قطع العلاقات
دبلوماسي مع إسرائيل لأنه يبدو لي
ومن شأن ذلك أن يرسل رسالة سياسية
صحيح ونحن لا نريد أن يكون لدينا أي شيء
ماذا تفعل مع مجرم حرب مثل
مثله
زعيم و